six times three eighteen yep doesn't
take a lot of twos
powell gets inside and pal now in double
figures
with eleven seven of them here in this
third quarter as drummond was upset
yeah him and finney smith got a little
tied up morden tied up penny smith
grabbed the jersey of
drummond for some reason and both guys
let their feelings be known
and taylor is gonna call is gonna go
against dallas here
it appears i was explaining something in
rick carlisle and his reaction was
upset jenny smith jumped on the back of
drummond and drummond
got him off and then he grabs his jersey
because drummond discarded him that's
nothing
global ben taylor and jp derosa the
officials
tonight
i used to love moments like this getting
into it with
opposing players whether it was a big
guy or a guy my size didn't matter
triggers altercations it's not gonna
last so what what you're gonna do you
just
swell up and you start talking to trash
and give them a game face knowing that
nothing's gonna come up
that's what i did with morning you know
and you know what's funny about that
how much would you have paid for just
like yeah go ahead
you in warning how long do you think i
would have lasted three seconds
no absolutely not less than three
seconds you think
yeah no question i think i would have
run around enough where he wouldn't have
caught me
whatever happened to the jeff van gundy
that was raised in a tough neighborhood
that would have handled alonzo martin
hey listen fine hill baby martinez
california
all those in northern california know
vine hill
but that's nothing i mean like finney
smith didn't do anything he's just
backing away